[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing death
however we're not going to be discussing
death in the traditional sense
i.e moving on to the afterlife we're
going to be discussing
death personified now if you're aware of
the tale of deathly hallows
which you certainly should be then
you'll remember a figure that was
representative of death
he was the concept of death in one
figure a personification
of that which represents an end finality
death is an interesting topic in harry
potter not only because of the figure
from the tale of three brothers
but also because of how it's depicted
where in our own world
death can sometimes be much more
permanent and traditional
the derivation of death which exists in
harry potter
is much more open-ended before we get
into that too deeply
i want to say that everyone has a
different perspective of death
whether it's rooted to your religion or
just your level of spirituality
harry potter portrays death quite
uniquely as it makes a clear distinction
between the body
and the soul with the body purely being
a vessel
that carries your vital life force the
soul within
the soul is a common theme within the
harry potter story and time and time
again report to its significance
and its relationship to death when
someone's soul is sucked out of them by
dementor they're not considered dead
but almost and this notion of being
almost
dead or in some kind of limbo state is
repeated across harry potter in varying
ways
whether it's in the form of ghosts
shades or the dead
reincarnated in harry potter death is
much less finite
and there are many ways that your soul
can continue to live on
not necessarily always traveling all the
way to the afterlife
but perhaps the most unique
representation of death in harry potter
is its personification the figure from
the tale of the three brothers
which tells the story of the deathly
hallows who is this figure
did he really exist or is it an old
wives tale
the original story of the deathly
hallows comes from the tales of beatle
the bard
fictional stories written for young
witches and wizards meant to contain
lessons or
morals however we clearly see in the
harry potter books that the hallows
mentioned from his story
actually exist the elder wand the
resurrection stone
and the invisibility cloak so my
question is
just how far from fiction was beatles
tale clearly there's
some truth to it but how much more
importantly
is death a real figure from the tales of
beedle the bard
there were once three brothers who were
traveling along a lonely
winding road at twilight in time the
brothers reached a river
too deep to wade through and too
dangerous to swim across
however these brothers were learned in
the magical arts
and so they simply waved their wands and
made a bridge appear
across the treacherous water they were
halfway across it when they found their
path blocked
by a hooded figure and it was death he
was angry that he had been cheated out
of three new victims
four travelers usually drowned in the
river but death was cunning
he pretended to congratulate the three
brothers upon their magic
and said that each had earned a prize
for being clever enough to evade him
so the oldest brother who was a
compassive man asked for a wand more
powerful than any
in existence a wand that must always win
battles for its owner
a wand worthy of a wizard who had
conquered death
so death crossed to an elder tree on the
banks of the river
fashioned a wand from a branch that had
hung there and gave it to the oldest
brother
then the second brother who was an
arrogant man decided that he wanted to
humiliate death still further
and asked for the power to recall others
from death
so death picked up a stone from the
riverbank and gave it to the second
brother
and told him that the stone would have
the power to bring back the dead
finally death turned to the third
brother a humble man
he asked for something that would enable
him to go forth from that place
without being followed by death and so
it was
the death reluctantly handed over his
own cloak of invisibility
in essence death gave all three brothers
one of the fabled deathly hallows
and they all had their own unique fate
no brother wanted to ever see death
again
but that wouldn't have ever been
possible the first brother was killed in
his sleep
and death took him for his own the
second brother tragically ended his own
life
which meant that you guessed he met
death once again
the last brother who claimed the
invisibility cloak was a wiser
better man and he used his cloak to
escape death for most of his life
however when the third brother finally
reached an age where he was happy with
what he had accomplished
he took the cloak off and graciously met
death once again
effectively choosing to depart the world
of the living regardless of the decision
that the brothers made
or the actions they took they ultimately
all face death once again
and the way that it's depicted in the
story shows them physically encountering
the same
personification of death from earlier if
the tale is real
how did beetle know about what had
happened or of the relationship between
death and the brothers
did beetle write fact or fiction one
thing to consider
is the tales of beadle dabard
continually reinforced
the stories are in fact the author's
original creations
however that certainly doesn't mean that
beedle
did not draw inspiration from his life
experiences the things that he had done
or the people that he had met jk rowling
surprised the following
foreword to the book if his stories
accurately reflect his opinions
he rather liked muggles whom he regarded
as ignorant rather than malevolent
he mistrusted dark magic and he believed
that the worst excesses of wizard kind
sprang from the all-too-human traits of
cruelty
apathy or arrogant misapplication of
their own talents
the heroes and heroines who triumph in
his stories
are not those with the most powerful
magic but rather those who demonstrate
the most kindness
common sense and ingenuity there's
little evidence to support either
argument
that the stories were fabricated
entirely or that beedle drew inspiration
from something that he had witnessed in
his life
however given that the hellos actually
exist i'm willing to bet that it was a
latter
we know that three hallows genuinely
exist and that can be confirmed
but was the personification just beedle
adding his own spin to the story
how can we be sure that death wasn't
just a powerful dark wizard
could it be possible that the three
brothers were talented wizards that just
created the hallows themselves
as it stands there is no proof that
suggests that death personified is
indeed real
his existence is only mentioned in one
work
and it's a fictional one to say that
death exists because of this one book
for children
is a stretch particularly as the
existence of the hallows
is the only real argument one could make
for his existence
and there could be many ways the hallows
themselves were created
albus dumbledore a respected wise old
wizard
doesn't seem to have much faith in the
validity of death's existence
so it's true ask to harry all of it
the peverell brothers were the three
brothers of the tale
dumbledore nodding oh yes i think so
whether they met death on a lonely road
i think it more likely that the pevel
brothers were simply gifted
dangerous wizards who succeeded in
creating those powerful objects
the story of the mean death's own
hallows seems to me the sort of legend
that might have sprung up around such
creations and i'm with dumbledore on
that one
there are many powerful artifacts in the
harry potter universe and the hallows
though powerful don't seem outside the
realm of possibility
i don't think the death existed but am i
certain
certainly not what do you guys think let
me know
in the comments section below until next
time
remember to the well-organized mind
death is but the next great adventure
[Music]
you